if there's one thing that Stargate
Atlantis taught us it said the Ancients
were complete dumb asses welcome to SRE
your Sci-Fi TV and M
[Music]
channel so when the international
Expedition first arrived at Atlantis
they were full of wonder well no
initially they were full of oh my God
we're all going to drown but once that
was all sorted they were full of wonder
it was a city of Miracles it was a city
ship that in lots of ways shouldn't have
existed it had the power and it held so
many secrets that they just boggled with
the anticipation of walking through each
and every door they found many many
dangers in that City constantly almost
through every door almost in every
cupboard and it really did shine a light
on just how stupid the Ancients were or
perhaps maybe the correct word is
arrogant no stupid too I'm going to go
with stupid why do I say that well one
big problem is they don't seem to be
able to turn anything off the Ancients
were not driven out of the city like
last minute they weren't my God all oh
my God oh my God we're all going to die
just get through the gate as quickly as
possible they evacuated the city they
decided to sink the city ship hide it
and leave Earth they did have time to
turn the damn lights off they definitely
had time to turn all the potentially
catastrophic killing machines off in
every bloody room the SG Atlantis crew
went through they found something else
that tried to kill not just them but
everybody Rodney and Shephard were
playing that computer game thing where
it was actually controlling entire
species of world loads of them
the Ancients didn't turn it off they
could have hung a at least saying don't
play with this it's not a game over here
when we bury nuclear waste there's
actually quite a lot of effort put into
the thought that in 10,000 years
somebody might dig this up in that case
we need to make sure that you know it's
dangerous the Ancients never even
crossed their mind that the humans that
they left on Earth might at some point
learn how to use the Stargates and
travel to Atlantis actually anybody
could have traveled to Atlantis what if
the gold W had turned up and they left
everything pretty much turned on how
many times did Rodney accidentally turn
on something in the SGU Corridor or room
that then either turned him into
superhuman that nearly killed him turned
everybody into ghosts that nearly killed
everybody released a sort of nanobot
ghost thing or some other thing or or
created a bloody replicator I know that
ended end up going quite well but Nano
viruses
plagues everything that Bloody city was
full to the brim of dangerous stuff and
there wasn't even a warning sign or an
off switch at no point do the Ancients
seem to consider the possibility that
the city would ever be inhabited by
somebody else How about if the janii had
found it or any other human race they
were lucky really that it was us what if
a Jaffer Expedition had come across the
location of Atlantis by accident and the
go W may have had a zpm and they could
have gone if the go world had got into
that City particularly with their
intelligence imagine the absolute crap
show they could have created back here
in our own Galaxy imagine the power they
would have wielded they wouldn't have
been worried about the Asgard anymore
The Shield technology alone would have
been them vastly superior but nothing
was guarded the Atlantis Expedition
turned up plugged a bunch of laptops in
and cracked on they didn't need to break
any special security measures they
didn't need to do anything the Ancients
didn't even lock the damn door they
could have left the shields running on
the actual Stargate they didn't even do
that I know a lot of this technology
could only be activated if you happen to
have the gene the ancient activation
Gene so that is the protection in theory
the problem is loads of people have got
it the ancestors of the Ancients have
all got it and I don't know if you've
ever noticed but not all humans are
actually good or even remotely
intelligent a lot of us are quite cruel
quite sadistic and quite stupid so any
of those humans with that Gene could
have activated this technology and how
hard do you really think it would have
been for the gold world to figure out
how to circumvent that now I know The
Wraith never did but the go W had a lot
more experience with humans and actually
a little bit more knowledge about the
Ancients they would have been able to
probably quite quickly circumvent the
tall Gene thing technology so that
safety measure really isn't that safe
now how many times even in sg1 did
Colonel O'Neal or somebody else stick
their head in a wall that was glowing
something you should never do and then
basically have the entire ancient
knowledge downloaded into their brain or
found some sort of weather device that
could change time or something else the
furlings Left Behind loads of Technology
they were no better than the Ancients in
lots of ways but the Ancients had
millions of years to learn how to put in
an off button they had ages before
having to evacuate the City to at least
turn things off or make them AER destroy
a lot of the experiments that wraith
could have found the ancient city of
Atlantis at any point they could have
figured out how to get around the
technology or at very least just by
looking at it learned an awful lot that
would have really been a massive problem
for the Pegasus Galaxy the Atlantis
should have been destroyed when the
atlanteans left for earth I don't think
they have had any intention of coming
back they should have scuttled the city
but they didn't why so the story could
happen but also possibly because they
were just so arrogant and so stupid it
never even occurred to them to do it so
yeah in my opinion the Ancients were
dumb asses it did make for a brilliant
show because they were dumb asses so
guys get into the comments and tell me
what you think is it just brilliant that
they were so stupid and left so much
technology lying around it was lucky for
the show it made it way more interesting
or actually is it a bit of a logical
leap that any of this would have
happened or that they wouldn't have
actually cleaned up after themselves and
you know maybe destroyed a few of those
experiments instead of leaving them just
ticking over I don't know what you think
but I think yeah get into the comments
though and tell me if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and you'll never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to
patreon.com Sidra where most of our new
videos appear first and for a small
contribution each month you get to see
those videos without the adverts and you
even get a free gift can't say fair than
that also go to c.co UK which is our
dedicated sci-fi website where you get
to see articles written about most of
our videos and I try to add a little bit
more detail for you to sink your teeth
into as always please stay safe and I
see you next
time